hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast dopamine system dysregulation
NE pathophysiology of schizophrenia and
depression I am Judy O'Rourke and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been proved for a category one
continuing medical education credit by
Loma Linda University if you are
interested in obtaining CMI's after
attending this presentation please click
on the get your free CME credits button
in the bottom left corner of the event
screen this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
could click on the support button at the
top right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the dream
Q&A button lower-left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Anthony
a grace dr. Anthony grace is a
distinguished professor of neuroscience
and a professor of psychiatry and
psychology at the University of
Pittsburgh in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania he
received his PhD from Yale University
School of Medicine dr. Benjamin s Bunny
and had postdoctoral training dr. Rhodes
also leanness in the department of
physiology and biophysics at New York
University School of Medicine dr. grace
has been involved in translational
research related to the dopamine system
for over 30 years
his early work pioneered mode of action
of antipsychotic drugs and the
identification and characterization of
dopamine containing neurons and was the
first to provide a means to quantify
their activity State and pattern in a
way that is
in the literature his current work
involves novel treatments for
schizophrenia and its prevention the
role of dopamine in anhedonia and
affective disorders and the mode of
action of ketamine and novel
antidepressant drugs dr. grace has
received numerous awards for his
research I will now turn it over to dr.
grace for his presentation
thank you very much Jeanne and welcome
all to this virtual conference what I'll
be talking about is some of the basic
work that we've been doing looking at
the dopamine system and its involvement
in different psychiatric conditions
especially looking at the regulation of
the system now this is a picture of the
dopaminergic system it consists of the
ventral tegmental area that's this
medial area and the substantial [ __ ] we
know that this area is involved in a
number of disorders including
Parkinson's disease schizophrenia and
drug abuse and there's emerging evidence
that it's also has a large involvement
in depression now in order to try to
understand the system what we want to do
is to be able to record from neurons in
the midbrain of an anesthetized rat to
understand how these systems are
regulated and how they may be
dysregulated in disease now how can we
record the activity across this
population of neurons well we know from
previous studies that there are a number
of neurons that are firing spontaneously
but also a number of neurons that are
quiescent and not firing the ones that
are firing or firing at different firing
rates and firing patterns so what we
would like to do is to find out exactly
what the population activity in these
neurons are to do this what we do is we
pass an electrode through the
substantial Niagra in a preset pattern
and count the number of neurons that are
acting per electrode track
this gives us an idea of the population
activity or just how many neurons are
active we then look at the neurons that
are active and see how fast they're
firing and also what their firing
pattern is when we look at firing
pattern what we find our individual
neurons fire at different types of
patterns in the baseline state they fire
in a slow irregular pop-pop-pop like
firing pattern but when the animal is
exposed to a behaviorally saline
stimulus dopaminergic neurons fired
bursts and action potentials these
bursts of action potentials are thought
to be the behaviorally relevant output
in the dopaminergic system and they
basically alert the brain but something
important has happened this burst firing
is controlled by a brain stem area
that's known as the particular pontine
tegmentum this provides a glutamatergic
input to the dopaminergic neurons in the
ventral tegmental area if we activate
this by injecting a gaba antagonist by
Kingkiller to activate this area what we
find is a selective increase in burst
fire without getting a change in the
number of neurons firing or their firing
rate now this is consistent with what we
know about system the glutamatergic
input that comes in activates NMDA
receptors but for NMDA receptors to
activate a neuron the neuron has to be
spontaneously firing if it's not
spontaneously firing there's a magnesium
block of the NMDA channel and it doesn't
change state which means only the firing
neurons will burst fire now what
regulates how many neurons are firing
well this is regulated by a different
part of the brain an area called the
ventral pallidum ventral pallidum is the
ventral part of the Globus pallidus it
provides a very potent GABAergic input
to these dopaminergic neurons it also
fires in high frequencies what we
believe is that this area holds subsets
of these neurons in the silent inactive
state
but if we inactivate this inhibitory
input this removes the inhibition and
allows the neurons to start firing now
what's the relevance as far as the
number of neurons firing
well this tonic activity controls the
level of amplification so in other words
the ventral pallidum controls the number
firing the potential upon kin controlled
burst firing burst firing being the
signal for the behaviorally relevant
output but the number of firing is the
gain so the more neurons that are firing
the more neurons the pedunculopontine
can make burst fire this system we think
plays a major role in the psychotic
Symphony schizophrenia schizophrenia is
a thought disorder comprised of three
major symptom classes positive symptoms
negative symptoms and cognitive symptoms
the positive or the psychotic symptoms
have the greatest association with an
overactive dopamine system we've used an
animal model based on a direct
disruption of neuronal development with
a compound called man or methyl azide
see methanol acetate this is the DNA
methylating agent we find when we give
to pregnant rats at gestational day 17
will cause a disruption in the system
that when the rats reach adulthood mimic
a lot of the things that we can measure
in an animal that correlates with what
we see in stings of fermentations
now it's published already the number of
characteristics of these animal models
that are consistent with what we see in
humans so as far as anatomical evidence
we see a thinning of the limbic cortical
structures and increased cell packing
density basically the same structures
and the same changes that we see in
human schizophrenia brains postmortem
we also see deficits in behavior we see
deficits related to cognitive symptoms
such as extra dimensional shift deficits
and negative symptoms such as social
interaction and latent inhibition and
also deficits related to sensory systems
such as
paraben-free call send mission started
we also find pharmacological evidence
including increased responses to PCP
which has also been reported instance of
Renia patients and increased left motor
responses to amphetamine now
interestingly we see this in the adult
but we don't see it when the animals in
the pre-pubertal stage which is
consistent with schizophrenia positive
symptoms occurring in late adolescence
early adulthood but not in pre purity
now this increased amphetamine response
is consistent with the role for dopamine
and schizophrenia there's a plethora of
evidence to suggest that dopamine has an
involvement in schizophrenia all
antipsychotic drugs that are in use
today work on dopamine receptors and are
primarily dopamine antagonists also
antipsychotic drugs varum fetta mean in
l-dopa
things that increase dopamine release
tend to exacerbate or worsen psychosis
and schizophrenia patients and can lead
to schizophrenia symptoms in normal
individuals in imaging studies revealed
an increased emphatically stuff Amin
release in schizophrenia that correlates
with psychosis however despite years of
search there's not evidence for a
primary deficit in the dopamine system
itself instead we now believe the
dopamine system is probably normal but
is dis regulated by other structures
primarily among these hippocampus so in
the man model of schizophrenia there's a
hyper responsility the dopamine system
analogous to that observed in
schizophrenia patients in current
clinical data shows that there's hyper
activity in the hippocampus especially
the bench look at the campus of rats
which correlates with the anterior at
the campus of humans it corresponds with
the psychotic State schizophrenia now is
the hippocampus hyperactive in the NAMM
animal his imaging studies have shown in
schizophrenia patients well when we look
at firing rate we find that the ventral
hippocampus is firing significantly
faster in the man
but firing rates a rather simplistic
measure of activity we know that the
campus also responds based on different
frequencies and rhythms and what we find
when we analyze the rhythms is a
decrease selectively in the very low
frequency 0 to 4 current rhythms that
are important for functional gating and
an increase in the higher frequency
rhythms suggesting that we're losing
this gated output and instead getting a
high frequency noise from the other
system now does this also affect
dopaminergic neuron activity well when
we look at our 3 parameters of
dopaminergic activity number of neurons
firing firing rate and firing pattern
what we find there's a selective
increase in the number of neurons firing
more than doubling in the number of
neurons without changes in firing rate
the firing pattern now the increased
number of dopaminergic neurons firing is
consistent with what seemed clinically
studies by Oliver house and Phillip
Maguire in the UK showed that in
schizophrenia patients there's an
increase in Florida per label turbot
terminals of the dopaminergic system in
the striatum
now fluorodopa labels active terminals
in the increased number of terminals
that they see is consistent with the
increased number of dopaminergic neurons
firing that we see in the mam rat so
when the hippocampus is hyperactive it
drives the ventral stratum nucleus
accumbens which then inhibits the
ventral pallidum and causes this number
of dopaminergic neurons firing to
increase we know that this is driven by
the hippocampus because if we activate
the hippocampus in normal animals you
don't see much of a change but in the
man-animals it brings dopaminergic
firing right back down to normal without
changing the other parameters suggesting
that it's the hippocampal hyperactivity
that's driving this increased number of
dopaminergic neurons firing which again
is consistent with hippocampal
hyperactivity in the human's
schizophrenia patient we
to this increased number of dopaminergic
terminals active now does this change in
dopaminergic firing translate the
behavior well in the normal animal if we
give a dose of amphetamine we get an
increased local motor behavior in the
Manimal what we find is the increase in
locomotion is substantially greater than
what we see in controls but if we
inactivate the ventral hippocampus
something that brings dopaminergic
firing back to normal we also bring
behavioral response to amphetamine back
to normal we don't eliminate it we just
bring it back to what we see in controls
so when hippocampal overdrive seems to
lead to increase dopaminergic neuron
population activity which we think is
the basis for this type of
responsibility the dopamine system in
schizophrenia now how does the increase
in dopamine population activity affect
the response of the dopamine system to
behave releasing stimuli well what we
think is that if a animal or if a person
isn't a benign contest you're sitting at
home and the safe neighborhood behind
locked doors hippocampus has the
dopamine system adjusted very little not
a lot of dopaminergic neurons fired now
whenever a signal comes you hear a noise
outside it'll activate the particular
pontine tegmentum which will then
activate dopaminergic neurons in the
burst firing but because they're earned
a lot firing the dopamine response is
rather low so you'll turn around see
what the noise was
and then calmly go back to what they
were doing before but if you're in an
activating context you're an animal out
hunting where every noise is something
that you could eat or something that
might cause you harm in this case the
hippocampus has the dopaminergic system
toned up very hot a lot of neurons fired
now the same noise is going to cause a
much greater number of dopaminergic
neurons the first fire in a much greater
dopamine response you're going to be on
edge ready to rapidly respond and orient
towards the stimulus to identify what it
is and what about the case of the
schizophrenia patient in this case the
hippocampus is hyperactive
this causes the dopaminergic system to
have a large number of neurons firing
spontaneously essentially every neuron
because of this any stimulus that comes
in salient or not is going to cause a
massive dopamine release which means the
schizophrenia patients aren't going to
be able to select between behaviorally
salient stimuli and irrelevant stimuli
because all of them are going because in
maximum dopamine activation and require
maximum detention as if there are very
threatening stimulus to the patient
which is exactly what they report the
inability to screen out what's relevant
from what's irrelevant importantly it
also means that the system is going to
be activated by stimuli that normally
could be ignored so for example one
looks out the window and sees two
complete strangers talking to each other
this is something that most of us would
completely ignore but to the
schizophrenia patient the dopamine
system is going to be screaming at their
brain that this is something really
important for our survival which means
they're going to have to figure out why
these two strangers have such a strong
emotional response and they're going to
confabulate this is the CIA spying on
them these are aliens planning to abduct
them this kind of aberrant salience that
should teach the poor has talked about
with respect to the improper attribution
of importance to irrelevant stimuli
characteristic of schizophrenia so when
the hippocampus is hyperactive the
dopamine system is hyper responsive to
stimuli and results in over
interpretation of events so these data
show in the mad model of schizophrenia
the ventral hippocampal hyperactivity
leads to a hyper response and dopamine
system that we think underlies the
psychotic state why is the ventral
hippocampus hyperactive well the most
consistent finding with people of maidan
schizophrenia patients is a very
substantial decrease of nearly 30% in a
specific type of GABAergic inhibitory
engine are those that contain the
peptide Pardo humor this is found to be
decreased across the hippocampus
selectively in schizophrenia patients
compared to other types of individuals
similarly in the mam animal we find
decreases in Pardo human neurons in the
hippocampus and in the prefrontal cortex
just as been reported by David Lewis and
others in schizophrenia patients
so the mam rats showed a regionally
selective reduction in these GABAergic
inhibitory Pardo Union inter neurons so
evidence suggests both in schizophrenia
and the man model there's hyperactivity
at the campus do this decreased inter
neuron function and if we inactivate the
ventral hippocampus they can restore a
normal dopamine system function now how
can we fix this pathological increase in
dopamine activity to treat schizophrenia
well current antipsychotic drugs act by
blocking dopamine receptors in the
stride and by an activating dopaminergic
neuron firing however the site of action
of antipsychotic drugs doesn't
correspond in the pathophysiology in
schizophrenia these drugs were
discovered by serendipity rather than by
a focused effort to try to treat
schizophrenia so although we believe the
deficit is in this interneuron pyramidal
neuron interaction in the hippocampus
where we treat schizophrenia is actually
by blocking dopaminergic receptors in
the striatum which is 1 2 3 4 5 synapses
downstream from where we think the
problem was which is she comes as no
surprise that these drugs probably
aren't as effective as we would like
them to be a better approach would mean
treating the site of pathology we think
the site of pathology again is that this
part of human pyramidal neuron
interaction
Parimal vehement interneurons are driven
by NMDA receptors and in fact this is
where we think drugs like PCP act to
worsen the symptoms of schizophrenia
because they decrease the activity of
the already diminished part of human
internals what we would like to do is
potentiate the effects of gaba at the
sinners but gap is difficult to
manipulate because it's more than 30 the
synapses in the brain and why can't not
selectively potentiate like with the
benzodiazepine like I am because this is
very highly sedating however Nature has
given us a handle on this in that in the
hippocampus there's a selective increase
in these they make GABA a receptor
subtype that contains a certain sub
needle now benzodiazepines bind together
receptors at the alpha 5 subunit there
the alpha subunit and there are six
distinct alpha subunits but only the
Alpha 5 subunit is concentrated with
hippocampus so what we wanted to do is
to get a selection gaba a benzodiazepine
or positive allosteric modulator which
we obtained from Jim Cooke and Madison
Wisconsin and what we find is that
whenever we use the Selective dab urgent
compound we do get selecting the effects
we can get this decrease in the
activation of the dopant of the internal
cortex the hippocampal pathway in the
hippocampus by stimulating the anti
ronald cortex but in another area we
looking at cingulate cortex the thalamic
evoked response and the cingulate cortex
is not effective even at ten times this
dose so what we see is a rather
selective effect in the hippocampus
would we look at this gaba-a alpha 5
positive allosteric modulator on
dopaminergic neuron firing we also see a
selective effect it has no effect in
control animals but in the man treated
animals that brings dopaminergic neuron
firing right back down to baseline
levels furthermore whenever we look at
behavioral effects although the effects
of amphetamine induced locomotion are
rather variable in the Sailing animal in
the mam animal that brings the hyper
locomotion right back down to baseline
levels so what we're doing is we're
actually restoring both dopaminergic
neuron firing as well as the behavior
response to amphetamine by the
hippocampus select the drug now why
isn't this drug used in the clinic well
the concern is that there are a number
of drugs that have showed promise in
preclinical studies that have failed in
the clinic a potential issue is the
difference in schism in the
schizophrenia patient although one made
it's been suggested that the reason
these drugs are filled is because we
can't translate from animal studies to
humans a concern is that there's a big
difference in the way schizophrenia
patients and treated they basically been
given antipsychotic drugs for decades
and then withdrawn for one week before
the drug is tested and we know that the
opem energic blockers changed the system
they basically make the system super
sensitive so what we did is to test the
impact of anti-psychotic drug treatment
and withdrawal on the man model and what
we find is that unlike the normal case
what we don't pretreat the animal and
get therapeutic actions if we look at a
rat that has been treated with
haloperidol for three weeks withdrawn
for one week now we find that our gaba a
alpha v compound has no effect in fact
inactivation of the hippocampus has no
effect
and with respect to behavior what we
find is that the animals are still hyper
responsive to the effects of amphetamine
despite the Alpha 5 compound or
inactivation individual at the campus
essentially the antipsychotic drugs have
changed the system from a hippocampal
order driven dopamine system the
postsynaptic super-sensitive immune
system this is a thing again showing
this increased locomotion with the hella
paranoia pretreatment but not with the
pretreatment so haloperidol or
anti-psychotic drug pretreatment what is
the capacity the system to respond to
and not Allegiant and as long as
clinical trials are done in chronic
schizophrenia patients it's not clear
that we're going to be able to get these
novel compounds that may have tremendous
efficacy the SHO actions in these two
kinds of clinical trials so in
schizophrenia and demand model inter
neuron dysfunction made me a primary dry
or symptomatology if we can restore
inter neuron function within these
circuits and could have an effective
therapeutic strategy
the thing is schizophrenia we know is
bad for the brain and is quite stressful
a better approach would be if we could
prevent the transition in schizophrenia
to begin with we know that stress plays
a major role across psychiatric
disorders stressful stimuli and
schizophrenia patients exacerbate the
positive symptoms in this disorder and
we know from studies by a Johnston Robin
Murray and others that stress can play a
role in schizophrenia we Johnstone did a
prospective study looking at a number of
children that were at risk for
schizophrenia and did a number of
psychometric tests on them and then
followed them to see who transitioned
Schmitt's afrien Ian what she found are
the children that were hyper responsive
distress tended to be the ones that
converted to schizophrenia
we also know that stress can lead to par
mobium an interneuron loss in the campus
which are the same neurons that are lost
in schizophrenia patients and in the man
where
so we believe in normal individuals
areas like the prefrontal cortex can
limit the response to stress but if the
prefrontal cortex is in the deficit
state we think this can initiate a
cascade of events that magnify the
effects of stress and need to in turn
your own loss and schizophrenia in
adults so in the normal animal stress
activates and as a cortical dopamine
release which activates the prefrontal
cortex and feeds back and inhibits
stress responses but if there's a
deficit either in the dopamine input to
the prefrontal cortex as david lewis's
data suggests or in the different
regulations of the dopamine system this
is going to lead to increased stress
responses the inability to activate the
prefrontal cortex is going to remove the
prefrontal cortical inhibition of the
amygdala which is going to magnify
stress responses this is going to lead
to activation of the neurons allergic
system the locus coeruleus which is
going to magnify stress responses this
will lead the glucocorticoid release
hippocampal damage may be the
magnification of the stress response in
this reentrant mute where a stressor is
going to have magnified effects and
magnified pathology now our Lam rats
more sensing the stressors as is
proposed to occur in the premorbid
statements Pizza Freni n' what we find
or the demand treated rats are more
responsive de-stress mild foot shocks
induce vocalization and control animals
but the level above is a vocalization is
much larger and longer duration in the
mam treated animals furthermore if we
look at a measure of anxiety the number
of times
rats explore and open arm compared to a
closed arm we find that the mam rats
tend to stay in the protected
environment which is consistent with
anxiety-like behavior so stress plays a
role in the developmental teeny ology in
schizophrenia this suggests that we can
intervene early on we can help prevent
the transition to psychosis we tested
this
in our man model by administering the
anti-anxiety agent I he's a Pam Perry
puberty so we basically gave the brats
either Namur saline during gestation
then for ten days around puberty gave
them dies at him we withdrew the
diazepam waited for them to reach
adulthood and then tested it and what we
found is that the bam rats that were
treated Perry puberty with diazepam the
anti-anxiety agent showed a
normalization of dopaminergic neuron
firing in the adult similarly they show
a normalization in amphetamine induced
hyper locomotion suggesting that
controlling these stressors early on in
life even an animal that's been
genetically predisposed because of man
treatment can prevent the transition to
psychosis so converging evidence from
clinical and basic science studies
suggests the inability to regulate
stress early in life for me to
pathological changes and then at the
campus that may underlie the emergence
of schizophrenia an adult but if we can
identify susceptible individuals and
intervene early enough basically
identifying people of genetic risk and
seeing if they're hyper responsive
distress just by treating the stress not
necessarily with drugs but with
psychosocial intervention we might be
able to prevent the transitions friendly
now another disorder in which the
dopamine system is believed to play a
role is major depressive disorder major
depressive disorder is a devastating
illness that affects as much as 15% of
the population throughout their lives
it's a chronic pervasive disorder
responsible for enormous loss of quality
of life and societal function in the
affected individuals the thing is is the
antidepressant drugs we have today
aren't as efficacious as they would like
and at least 30% of the patients aren't
responsive at all
furthermore it takes 46 weeks to get
therapeutic actions these drugs work on
the serotonin system
but just like antipsychotic drugs the
use and discovery of these drugs was
more by serendipity than it was because
of any kind of intelligent design but we
know that the dopamine system actually
plays a role in a number of things we've
seen in depression multiple studies have
shown that if you intend you ate the
dopamine system you can get a state of
anhedonia
or an inability to drive pleasure from
the environment which is a primary
characteristic of depression as is
behavioural despair it's also seen with
dopaminergic inhibition in a motivation
the dopamine system that we also examine
the role of the dopamine system in a
model of depression the model of
depression that we use is something
called the chronic mild stress model
this is where we give repeated mild
stressors nothing very extreme things
like having a wedding of the bedding one
day having the cage tilted another day
having the lights on for 24 hours the
next day basically chronic unpredictable
irritations that have been shown in a
number of studies to leave the
depressive lake behaviour in animal
models what we find when we expose rats
from these chronic mild stressors is an
increase in behavioral despair in the
for swim test
this is where rats are placed in a tub
of water and we measure how long they
spend searching for the state normal
rats mean swim around for a substantial
period of time looking for an escape
route when they finally figure out that
they can't escape
they basically float what we find in the
CMS rats is the CMS rats spent a lot
more time in mobile they basically give
up much faster which is an indication of
this behavior it's there what we find in
these animals is the opposite of what we
saw in schizophrenia patients the
decrease of nearly 50% in the number of
neurons firing
without changes in firing rate or
pattern now what pathway mediates this
decrease in dopaminergic neuron firing
and depression well studies by Helen
neighbors have identified one area the
sub genuine cingulate area 25 this area
is hyperactive and sad memory with
tryptophan depletion which can lead the
depression it shows morphological
changes in depression in any drug it's
effective in treating depression brings
this hyperactivity back down to normal
SSRIs normal antidepressant drugs
serotonin and norepinephrine reuptake
inhibitors transcranial magnetic
stimulation
electroconvulsive therapy being the
nerve stimulation deep brain stimulation
even placebos when they show a
behavioral response restore activity in
this area back down to baseline now what
happens if we activate the rat
equivalent in area 25 the infer limbic
prefrontal cortex and these innate the
normal rats or what we find is just
activating the infrared prefrontal
cortex gives us the same change is the
chronic mild stress a decrease by about
half the number of dopaminergic neurons
fired this enact this decrease in
dopaminergic neuron firing produced by
activation of the intra limbic
prefrontal cortex can be prevented if we
in activate the amygdala depression in
humans has been associated not only with
hyperactivity need for limited
prefrontal cortex but hyper
responsibility in the amygdala and in
fact if we activate the amygdala
directly we also get a decrease in the
number of dopaminergic neurons firing
this suggests that the amygdala is
what's actually driving the decrease in
dopaminergic neuron active
with chronic mild stress what we find
again is a decrease in the number of
dopaminergic neurons firing this we can
also reverse by inactivating the
amygdala now how does the amygdala
attenuate dopaminergic neuron firing
well there are a number of pathways
between the amygdala and the
dopaminergic system but one stands out
in particular the ventral pallidum the
area we think is inhibited in
schizophrenia what we find is that if we
activate the amygdala to decrease the
number of dopaminergic neurons firing if
we block the amygdala glutamatergic
input of the power T with this
glutamatergic block of tiny arena
cassidy we prevent the effects of
amygdala activation from changing
dopaminergic neuron activity so we
believe that when the amygdala is driven
it activates the ventral pallidum which
then decreases dopaminergic neuron
firing back down to control at the back
below these control levels now is the
infra limbic prefrontal cortex involved
well again if we get our chronic mild
stress rats we get a decrease in
dopaminergic neuron activity but if we
inactivate the infra limbic prefrontal
cortex we restore t1 so basically we
think that hyperactivity and currently
big prefrontal cortex is what initiates
this cascade of events that leads to a
decrease in the number of dopaminergic
neurons firing
so in depression the amygdala through
the prefrontal
infra limbic prefrontal cortex is
decreasing the number of dopaminergic
neurons firing
so stimuli normally associated with
reward cause a very strongly attenuated
dopamine response which we think can
lead to the standard on each state
the consequence again is this failure to
activate the dopaminergic system to
rewarding stimuli so what we have is a
dopamine activating circuit that we
think plays a role in schizophrenia and
we also have in stopa me an inhibitory
circuit and we think plays a role in
depression so we have two independent
systems that activate or attenuate
dopaminergic neuron responsive now
although that amygdala decreases
dopamine population activity and
depression you should earlier on that
stress activates the bench of the campus
which increases dopamine activity so we
would normally have a balance between
the amygdala activity and thus
avicularia tea even though these areas
actually interact with each other so
what changes in depression well to do
this we wanted to use a model it's also
an accepted model of depression but
something that we know can work on a
much more rapid sphere so what we use is
the learned helplessness model of
depression something that was developed
by Sun cell you man more that happened
half a century ago basically you place
rats in a box that has a barrier and you
expose them to a very mild but
inescapable foot shot and you do this
for one day the next day you give the
rats in this paper and what we find we
use these mr. Kyoto anxious rats is that
half the rats when they get an escape
route will escape but half the rats
don't escape they have learned that they
are helpless to control their
environment in a analogous manner to the
way depressed patients would feel
helpless to have any control over their
environment so what we find is that half
the rats escape but half the rats are
helpless now what we did is to try to
find a rapid reversal is we used a new
normal antidepressant drug kidding
Kahneman has been shown in clinical
trials to affect it rapidly reverse the
symptoms of depression after only a
single dose and this affected last for
me
ketamine turns helpless rats in benign
helpful spirits
now what about the dopaminergic system
well interestingly if we compare our
rats the non helpless rats show the same
number of dopaminergic neurons firing is
the control animals but the helpless
rats
we've got identical treatment show this
huge decrease in dopaminergic neuron
activity giving a dose of ketamine sorry
restores dopaminergic neuron firing in
the helpless animals to make them look
like the non helpless animals just like
ketamine reversed the helpless behavior
now why are we getting this effect while
in the excitatory path room is
hippocampus - accumbens pathway normally
if we stimulated at high frequencies we
get the potentiation specifically LTP
the long-term potentiation in this
pathway however in the helpless rats
what we find is just the opposite a
depression in this pathway with
activation we see this only in the
helpless rats not in the non helpless
rats ketamine will actually take this
Ltd and restore it tip no TP so whenever
you restore behavior as far as escape
behavior and restore dopaminergic neuron
firing we also restore normal plasticity
in this pathway so what we think is that
in the depressed patient there is an
inactivation in this facility Tori after
the pathway which means the inhibitory
pathway dominates the
to the depressed state now how do these
different systems be related to the
existence of schizophrenia and
depression
because obviously schizophrenia isn't
the opposite of depression well in order
to do this what we did is to compare the
two models the schizophrenia model in
the depressed model in the schizophrenia
model when we look at which parts of the
dopamine system are affected what we see
is that the biggest change tends to be
in the lateral aspects of the ventral
tegmental area in contrast in the
depression model the biggest decreases
that we see in the dopaminergic system
are in medial and central areas not in
the lateral areas now this is important
because these areas have different
functions
studies by Nyssa Abu Darda Midmark
Lorelle have shown that in schizophrenia
patient the biggest change and I'm fed
Amin induced dopamine release isn't the
associative Strader the associative
stratum is the place where the lateral
ventral tegmental area dopaminergic
neurons project in the wreck so the
dopaminergic system that's most
hyperactive in the rat is the one that
also shows the greatest increase in m13
induced opening release in the patient
however the medial areas the areas that
project to the reward related ventral
medial strain are the areas that seem to
be decreased in the chronic mild stress
model of depression and that are
involved in reward related behavior so
what we have is a differentiation with
the schizophrenia dopaminergic system
and the associative strata meaning
hyperactive but in depression the reward
related dopaminergic system is
hyperactive which is why these systems
can be independent and why we should be
able to have term organs
of affective disorder schizophrenia
depression in the same patient so
basically these studies suggest that in
the dopamine system we have distinct
roles in both schizophrenia and
depression and schizophrenia
hyperactivity in the hippocampal
excitatory circuit inhibits the pallidum
causing the salience related
dopaminergic neurons to be hyper
responsive to stimuli leading to this
interpretation of events and this we
think is responsible for the homeless
nations and delusions and schizophrenia
in contrast these chronic uncontrollable
stressors acting through the amygdala
decrease the reward related dopaminergic
activity leading to these decrease
dopamine system functions like decreased
motivation feelings of helplessness and
inability to derive pleasure from
experiences therefore although the
dopamine system may form the basis of a
number of psychiatric disorders the
pathology is more likely to originate
and regions involved in their apparent
control is it consequence of therapy
based on restoring normal function in
these regions is likely to be more
effective than directly manipulating
dopamine receptor stimulation then I
need to thank the people who are
involved in doing so much of this work
especially Pauline Bell John who was
involved in the depression work as well
as Jared Marines involved in depression
work the people involved in the
schizophrenia work Katie gillies
Stampler ESCO Neutron do Dan Lodge Holly
Moore who developed the mad model in my
lab in Eric Zimmerman brunella Valenti
who is involved in a lot of distress
work Maria
margarita Behrens he did the work with
you know sonic chemistry
Jim cook who worked with us in
developing the l5 compound that we found
to be so effective
thank you for your attention and not be
happy to answer questions yeah thank you
for that informative presentation before
we get started on the question and
answer session I would like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green join a button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can and our first
question is Lukas pardon me if I
mispronounced coriolis is a main source
of norepinephrine in human CNS it will
activate its activity directly or by
using selected any receptors agonists or
antagonists will they change da system
improvements she really is
provides a input into a number of
regions including the ventral
hippocampus in fact the ventral
hippocampus contains some of the
strongest norepinephrine inputs into the
system by activating the ventral
hippocampus we think stress will
actually lead to hippocampal Drive which
is why if you notice in some of these
cases if we actually injected a North
and efferent antagonist we changed the
system so we think stress can activate
the ventral hippocampus in order to
activate the dopaminergic system which
is seen with the keep strong stressors
we also know that stress activates the
northen effort input into the amygdala
which is responsible for the lot of the
anxiety states so we actually have this
interaction and stress it depends on the
intensity and stress the duration of the
stress and also the timing because acute
stressors while activating the dopamine
system withdrawal from very strong or
long stresses actually cognisant
activation that we think is responsible
for depression
how could two models of dopaminergic
dysfunction that he presented converge
and result in anhedonia reward related
dysfunctions in patients with
schizophrenia fortunately I can't read
the whole question here okay
we haven't actually looked at it it
would be interesting to look at
something like the chronic mild stress
model in the NAMM model and see if we're
getting changes what we think would
happen is that we would get a difference
between what's happening medially with
respect to the reward related dopamine
system and what's happening happening
laterally with respect to the these fits
for any related dopaminergic system
because what we think is we're getting a
differential control over the medial
lateral areas so we would be able to
activate the dopaminergic system in one
part leading to the schizophrenia
symptoms and inactivate it in another
part meaning to the depressive symptoms
but doing both in the schizophrenia
model will be quite interested um we
have a few questions regarding your
experience presenting virtually for lab
routes I'm sure you've presented and
physical conferences many times over the
course of your career how do you compare
it to presenting live in a virtual
environment presenting live in a virtual
environment has certainly has positive
and negative aspects
unfortunately I can't look at the
audience to see whether I'm losing their
interest or not but on the other hand it
also makes it so that I can reach a
number of people that I wouldn't
normally be able to reach
people that are in countries where
travel is more difficult or which I
haven't traveled to and certainly
students who can't afford to attend a
lot of the presentations that I would
give in other places so I really enjoy
being able to reach a broader audience
especially people who normally wouldn't
be able to attend and get this
information from such conferences do you
think this is the future of education
for the community whether something like
this can replace standard lectures is a
question certainly it's a way of being
able to reach a broader audience but
there's something about the one-on-one
interactions you can have with a class
or with an audience that you can't
replicate online so I think that they
both have their own roles and they both
have important ways to supplement each
other in order to most effectively reach
the target audiences without one
necessarily being better or less
effective than the other but each
playing their own role in order to most
effectively educate unfortunately we are
out of time I want to thank the audience
for their interesting questions and
participation in today's event
thank you dr. grace for your
participation and for your informative
presentation today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing for
several months following you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay meaning but you'd afford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye